yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing some more blitz games my
he still has to
couple of minutes but I can still start
no sound I know I got a song
I always need a little tick noises
let's see what's happening here see for
know London
yeah have many good systems against it
nothing really that is super exciting
just a very solid system
I often play play this variation I think
it's good and it's also what Daniel
bearish and I recommend in them in our
who goes in serious um
[Music]
yeah do I have to provoke f4 with Quincy
seven
think I should do that
just wondered if it is better to maybe
do it in a different move autumn
- and our Bishop e7 going night F know
ft6 is kind of north it says just one
night that can go to the six and now we
get to this very standard position which
is good for black not good in the sense
of that I'm winning right away or
something but it's very comfortable
yo we want to check with the night Inc
with the pawn is better tonight on the
two is not really
dangerous piece
this is interesting
I can now take on deform
I think I'll do that I think I'm quite
happy that he has to take with the C
pawn now as a pawn captures is answered
with III check
I mean he doesn't really have any
attacks Oh
rook c8 yes
see that Roxy one is not hitting me I
mean he can do that but
doesn't lead to anything
yeah hmm interesting
you
but I'm not sure about is if I should
trait here or not
I'm just playing it in a simple fashion
the the ending should be good for me
as well I'm in the middle game you can
argue is also very good for black but
let's go for the ending by the way this
video will be a little bit shorter than
usual for those sessions because I'm pre
recording this when this is released I'm
not at home usually I just record them
on the day when they're released or
sometimes the day before but I will not
be at home at the release date of this
video and traveling and I wanted to do
something record some videos beforehand
so that you have a daily
[Music]
a daily video basically but I cannot
record
like a couple of days worth of our
something videos and don't manage that
timewise so I'm just annoying here with
the bishop threatening b5
I would still play that I mean the night
has no good square to go to
or what about if I take what happens if
I take
96 that should basically win a pawn
right
and wins upon
I can even take first and then 96 but
then c5 is still a move as if I was a
move no not really
the who 96 he has Knight takes e4 though
which is a bit of a pain
that's silly I should have seen that I
should have seen that
not exactly difficult to spot
you
okay I mean the position is good without
anything fancy happening but
okay 94 now I'm going to take
it was just silly because I I could have
just kept my Bishop air and just have a
large advantage
I really didn't see this
Meishan correctly
you
it was completely unnecessary to give up
the bishop Pam that dead-ending was
super one-sided
no he's coming over to the kingside
cannot do much they're really
yeah I miss the technical the technical
ideas that was just not good
you
this is definitely clearly worse for me
I'm not sure if it's lost would be close
maybe he doesn't have a way forward
you
you
not happy about this that's what it's
for sure
you
you see five
maybe cannot completely dominate the
night
not
I should always be able after d5 to to
go to d7 at the end
you
it cannot go kingly - right there's a
check on c4
he wants to him I can take this pawn
only three right but I don't need to
rush this
he's killing himself here
and
I mean I can take on before it's not
really any rush
you can just pick up every porn you ever
liked
you
I was very really played
and white
in the end result is just what it was at
the beginning of the endgame but
it was still completely unnecessary the
main point here on my main mistake was
that here I thought that Bishop takes he
forest is good because of concrete lines
and it just isn't the case of a play
like b5 what I originally wanted this
position is terrible for white I'm just
dominating with the bishop here with
normal moves like Knight b6 or whatever
ni b6 is one of the engine moves
I'm just yeah better because all these
pieces are bad and here I assume blame I
wanted to originally play 96 in this
position and I miss that you can take
only form
it's a bit bit of a problem and yeah
that that was not good
king f7 was right
96 yeah right right
this is better
because I'm closer to the the f5 move is
not necessary really exactly and then I
can take and go 96 which is still a huge
advantage
yeah I've got a temple and I'm right in
time to stop his c-pawn okay that would
have been a lot better okay so a new
game or not fifteen fifteen if not in
this video let's play a normal three two
I should definitely
bring some team
you
and yeah this is featured heavily in my
cubic simple deform
surprisingly many players don't take on
b3 always surprised that they go Queen
c7
we're not not that it's not a terrible
move to go Queen c7 I just always feel
it's a bit surprising to me
kay early night or in this pollution
[Music]
dunno
and this I'm basically always happy to
see because
then pawn structure gets even more gets
improved
my main idea here is to get the night a
five
and attack the b7 pawn it's not so easy
to cover okay it does it like that
we should f4 very lightly we'll go
Bishop c7 now
yes my dad and now
let's gain space
form a for Knight f6 maybe but okay I'm
still I still want the space
[Music]
and that was not good
bad timing that was bad timing
no g-force is attacked
hmm
huh that
yeah that wasn't a good now we can put
something to e4 I wanted to play it in a
way that I have the night on d2 already
so that's something to e4 we'll always
end up in a pawn showing up on that
square and now this is not really
necessary
you could play Knight e4 which then
whatever it will take
or Bishop to a bishop f3m of course yeah
here I go Bishop f3 and
offer
trying to tempt him into taking when I
take with the pawn which would be pretty
nice actually I'm covering efore then
and tonight c1 d3 d5 it's the follow-up
okay so he's playing this
a interesting
not sure he has spotted this idea
English seven doesn't look like it maybe
he wants to just bring the King over to
CH that makes sense
so that the king is close to that b7
weakness that I'm not really attacking
anymore
I know yes
reconsidered
I didn't know f5
he doesn't react to the idea I think I'm
going to take this opportunity and
worsen his pawn structure a little bit I
wonder
I wonder if this first is better
actually
[Music]
yeah it is better because now King f6 I
can answer with night age five I just
wonder if this is good in the first
place
a knight aged five he can sacrifice the
exchange actually huh it's it's a bummer
really I wanted to play Knight h5 but
now I see that you can sacrifice the
exchange rook takes pawn takes h5 King
takes f5 and that is supporters
I have to have to still take
unfortunately
you
yeah the debts that was kind of that
didn't do that that didn't help I'd say
now night age five he just has king of
seven the idea of night age five before
trading was that king of seven was not
possible but he has this
[Music]
oh really that better for me
artists would just be better for white
maybe I'm wrong
you
you cannot play with p8 I mean
King and point ending is just toast
play e5
a let's say I take it and I play
that's going to be very dangerous for
luck
you
each trainee I transfer this count to
play with probably book each one
but I can go to
in go to f4 maybe King g5 is better now
no we didn't do that
now he's got this pawn
[Music]
chick is six
you
and I can just check me
you
and yeah I'm just going to
place my hope on those pawns here yeah
that should be pretty good
seven four more words already
can I just go behind the porn for the
moment ya think I can
you
maybe this is not the cleanest technique
but
it would be enough
now I need to pick up the porn
retinue group takes h3 and doesn't do it
react to that at all I mean
well okay it was lost anyway I think
no they just hit the wrong button
okay let's go for oh yeah I only have 20
minutes and this is in this video for
one or two more games I wanted to make
it roughly 30 minutes
so playing La Vie 12
should have looked at the game a little
bit actually there was too keen starting
a new one wanted to actually show this a
little part there with night age five
think about this for a moment we have
what helper do we have which ones post
and to an old Ben Oni
you
typical plan for blackest night 8g 697
f5 this kind of thing
very very slow
yeah I don't mind
trait nobody's thinking here you don't
play Bishop g4 and then then go back it
would be extremely odd
now let's go f4 and attack his center
to gain as much space as possible one
takes bishop takes there is a yeah here
there's pretty strong pressure already
on d6
let the move Bishop to f6 is not easily
playable
yeah against such a move you usually
just retreat
and wonder if this is right here
I mean Knight III is the typical way to
retreat
you
yeah why'd you also go to f5 let's do
that
you
young chip
the question is do I want to keep this
bishop or not
I think I want to keep it I mean he
might take only three just being happy
that this bless bishop now can be traded
[Music]
age for the CF 90/65 maybe
[Music]
to page four 90/65 that's painful
I wonder if you really spotted that
beforehand it's kind of
looks like
I know otherwise Bishop h4 would have
been extremely strong
[Music]
yes night c-form I mean even the move
before but I always think that Queen e2
should be good then
so this one threatening will gave six
I think that is a threat
you
maybe he doesn't think it's a threat
whoa
ship age 4 is still answered by night
xt5 which is really really annoying
annoying tactic
you know this one I'm I really don't
know what what the point is because now
night be - I just have rupee one the
same thing was working earlier
you
now let's see now I have a couple of
interesting options I can sacrifice the
exchange immediately and then play
Bishop h4
one I can take a five and take f6 for a
different exchange sacrifice both is
good for white the question is which one
is better
it's tough
you
think I'm going to
do it in a different way
because here I can actually keep this
tension a little bit my ideas to play 91
III at five and maybe filming this is
giving me some more options in some
cases I might even sacrifice another
exchange that could actually be very
dangerous
I think if it was my move now look f6g
takes Quincy forecheck
very very dangerous
so okay let's go for the night tour
you
you know it looks very strong actually
okay this is the kind of thing that I
wanted to provoke the question is now do
we sacrifice the exchange again on
how do we play it
and looks completely devastating let's
do it
Knight f5 and soap sooo bad
if he goes King edge 795 Queen whatever
Queen age five and resigns that's over
nice game and to exchange sacrifices
so Knight f5 and Quincy five check I
have Bishop f2
attacking the Queen and simultaneously
turning made into
maybe doesn't matter actually if I go to
h4 h5 it doesn't matter yeah that looked
nice right
then let's let's have a look I think
this is some this is yeah here the
question what is the best it's really
difficult the be sure the computer just
wants to play we should age for and this
is not like to that much by the engine
maybe it's I think it's good I mean
maybe it just takes a while to
appreciate we can put the first moves on
Bishop h4 and now it wants to play a 5-4
rook a 6 ok
so the problem is here that I have a
strong attack but probably not something
that is immediately winning yeah unless
the engine takes longer and then finds
an immediate win but I guess that after
age six I'm definitely winning that I'm
very sure about okay this is should when
I rock f6 is killing
and that that you cannot defend yeah
interesting okay so let's go for one
more game
you
here we go you go on
G 69 oh no that was the wrong pond
not be 5 please
came down that's an absolute mainline
of the symmetrical English
this one mm-hmm I have really forgotten
my atheria
the last time I checked this was when I
wrote the Banco gambit repertoire for
chess over my first ever chess table
repertoire it was in the summer of 2016
it's like lifetime ago
okay I can definitely play d5 and I'm
fine
this is the kind of position where white
is fighting for equality already it just
might be that I don't have anything
rage really d4 is going to equalize
um I just wonder ever have anything
better
yeah I think I can probably
which is a bit more ambitious
giving me a seven for the bishop in case
of night a form
I have a very reasonable iqp position
mostly because his pieces these pieces
here in Knight c3 not so much but those
two don't really do all that much
so we should be six he's got night a for
now I'm a little bit
yeah okay deform I had to move default
that was them let's say same way to do
it and just be equal and have no
problems
I'm played it in a bit more risky
fashion that is a strange move down but
are you Knights doing now
Retin in b5 okay and he goes back
what is the deal night f4
eat
I always have enough control over g4 so
I cannot ever be worse
more or less
now what if I go deform what is he doing
then evil
[Music]
category four and this is just good here
you
mmm if it takes how it takes here okay
now how do I capture here that's
interesting mmm Queen takes is more
aggressive trying to get the Queen to h4
I'm doing that why not
don't see a drawback
should be - was not really that tempting
oh I didn't see that move at all
it's kind of embarrassing
it doesn't look to be a big problem
because I'm so active iam that
it should be fine but I didn't see the
move at all like absolutely not
No now where's the Queen going Queen c2
maybe
is probably saved by Queen Texas
six-year okay
okay
what are you doing on v3 here
I can't play Bishop b2 now what is this
what I said what's the point
material
when they exchange back let's say
should be 6 and then 84 is also pretty
tempting
not not so good right so I go here right
well what is the point I don't
understand them all
ah okay
and then then he wants to move the night
at the point
I see okay that what's the point
yes
the easy thing to do is just to take on
b3 and play this ending it is I'm a poor
knob
just wonder if I got something better
we have to they're probably not
pants look look odd yeah they really do
look odd
but the two the two bishops are nice
nice
a he doesn't attack anything
still not so easy to coordinate him
you
like to
into on the second
okay too
a six is hanging but I want the bishop
only two and attack on the second ring
you
Bishop's are strong
mate next move g3
each one mate yeah um a bit of a bit of
an odd game didn't quite understand many
many things that were going on um yeah I
think I should be really fine even early
on like let's say here you can always
just completely equalize with the move
like deform that is just 0.1
I'm surprised that actually why should
have something here 26 us the initial
engine suggestion but a six this is all
okay em I mean this is this night tour
it's not so scary engine actually wants
to ignore the threats to be seven mayor
why not actually if we look at this
thank you this is probably just trapped
somehow Queen c7 qe7
maybe c7 it doesn't have a square that's
true
young you fine
g4s already winning more or less oh it's
very strong actually
that's very strong f3 doesn't work as
d-4s hanging was check and after a cream
or firming this is just terrible already
I'm having all kinds of threats we
should be too as well
Wow okay
yeah and this is also not bad um I mean
I have enough MFI enough play for the
exchange even more than that and TM okay
rook e8 was even stronger but I'm also
much better after the Queen trade as the
two bishops are so strong
okay guys hope you enjoyed the video
again as I mentioned a little bit
shorter than usual but I wanted to have
one up in the first place thanks a lot
for watching